let's talk about Sandra Bullock her new
Netflix thriller bird box screens
tomorrow and while promoting it Sandra
revealed her pre-holiday heartbreak my
dad died and then while my dad was
failing we get a call that our dog Ruby
the chew leg or had a stroke and I'm
like what what I was like just put her
on life support do something and they go
we can't she's she's suffering so I was
like okay there's a reason for this
while Sandra was visiting her dad in his
final days her nanny broke even more bad
news she goes your other dog has a heart
tumor and she's gonna die in three days
and I was like I'm gonna be fine and
then a week later I'm bathtubs crying
and the kids are like is mommy okay
really like just leave mommy in the back
though she's gonna be fine Sandra's son
Louie and daughter Lila helped her
recover from the family's tragedies
while shooting bird bots she was
terribly homesick for the both of them I
was tired I missed my kids I hadn't seen
them in three weeks I was having I mean
I saw them on the weekends but I had to
have a little fun I played a game with
Sandra and her co-star Avante Rhodes of
what's in the bird box I just want you
to reach in and grab a couple of things
and tell us what's in our bird box okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you